the Chess Club is a few blocks from here
we're currently hosting the US and US
women's championships I encourage you to
come by and check it out it's really
awesome ok with me today is Jennifer shy
Jennifer has been involved with the
Chess Club since we opened two no.9 to
been a very important part of our
process and development she is a
compensator for the u.s. Chess
Championships she can come out and watch
her live and Jennifer's also a two-time
US Women's Champion she's an author of
acclaim chess titles such as chess [ __ ]
and play like a girl she's great for
chess and she's also apparently a mind
sports ambassador for Poker Stars so she
is really a phenomenal person she's got
a lot of interesting things to say
thanks for joining us and without
further ado Jennifer thank you guys for
having me thank you Mike
so the first game I fell in love with is
actually right up here on the screen and
you could have played it on google Mac
so a couple of days ago it's not
actually at Pac Man I pleaded an acting
camp before I got really into chess
every night and the reason I played it
view is because I was very unpopular at
this camp no friends nobody beat meals
with toothpaste in my shoes that kind of
thing but I played the most popular and
best-looking guy in back man every night
at the canteen and it really taught me a
couple things first that games like
chess and poker crossed all sorts of
boundaries whether it be gender age race
social status in this case and it also
taught me before I got really serious
about the game of chess about this
really important link between strategy
and tactics so strategy in this case is
more like your plan to eat all the power
ballads right some of those red zones
are much more easy to get packed heard
by a ghost so you kind of want to attack
those first tactics on the other hand
it's really about can I get past the red
ghost before he eats me it's a really
short term calculation
am I gonna get checkmated or am I not
gonna get checkmated and in chess of
course this is very important now right
now I'm sure most of you know hopefully
you do that we are in st. Louis the
capital of chess in America for the last
couple years it was actually identified
by Congress as the capital of chess in
the United States and even here in st.
Louis we see this tension between
tactics and strategy with some of our
goals at the Chess Club Here I am with a
grandmaster yasser sarah juan doing
commentary on the strongest tournament
in history the Sinquefield cup so over
at the Chess Club which is in the
Central West End we do chess classes
chess tournaments we go to hundreds of
classrooms we also broadcast this to
chest hands from over 200 countries so
we're really tapping into chess fans and
existing chess players meanwhile across
the street at the world chess Hall of
Fame we have some more strategic goals
how to get more people interested in
chess it's already estimated that 35
million Americans play chess but I think
that number should be even higher and
what we do at the world chess Hall of
Fame with innovative exhibits like the
hip hop and chest exhibit that we have
going on right now which I encourage you
all to check out is to try to show that
chess is for everyone and that there are
links between chess and fashion there
was another exhibit recently called
the Queen we wit within which was all
about chess and fashion so in the game
itself
there's also tactics and strategy it's
really the key thing about chess when do
you think in a way where you calculate
to a checkmate or a win of a queen and
when do you think more in terms of long
term plans another very exciting thing
that we have going on in st. Louis for
chess is that the United States Chess
Federation just moved their corporate
headquarters here into this very
building cortex
and Jeanne Hoffman the executive
director of USCF actually gave a talk
just last week about innovation and
chess one of my favorite USCF events is
called the super nationals that's an
event where thousands of kids come to
compete in their age range and try to
become national champions a couple years
ago in Nashville we actually had a
record-breaking tournament it was the
largest tournament of all time we had
over 5,000 students competing so
strongest Chester and whenever the
Sinquefield Cup largest ever you can see
that chess in America really is booming
right now and here's a little clip from
one of the kids in the tournament about
what he likes about jazz I think I can
win the trophy and become a national
champion here I like a kid who said that
he likes the way his brain feels while
playing chess because that's definitely
how I feel when journalists asked chess
players about how they think in chess
the most common question we get is how
many moves do you think ahead really a
tough question to answer because it
varies a lot from position to position
here we have world chess champion Magnus
Carlsen who along that line played a
very interesting game against Bill Gates
anybody guess who want
well in fact Carlsen won the game in
nine moves and 39 seconds we see I think
very short named 79 seconds sorry but
the thing is 79 seconds but Magnus
actually only had 30 seconds to complete
the game so he really had to use his
seconds wisely but the interesting thing
was that everybody was making fun of
Bill Gates why we must be really dumb we
just came so quickly but on the funny
thing is that yeah
so he was winning the game in this very
position Carlson played a move where he
moved his night forward you see that
that green night in the middle of the
board that was Carlson's last move and
now white can capture that night as he
did and the Queen came down and
checkmate and that was Carlson's nine
move victory leader Carlson was very
modest guy I mean he's the number one
chess player in the world and also a
model so obviously has a lot to be
modest about later he said that huh he's
this was a cheap trick but you know he
shouldn't have gone for it
what do you I don't know how many of you
guys play serious chess here but in this
position Bill Gates could have actually
won so instead of capturing that night
what could he have done anybody see you
gonna get a winning position because if
you count the material on the board he's
actually a piece in this position so
he's ahead of material on Magnus Carlsen
any ideas how many people do play chess
you know I know you've got like a chess
tournament going on so I figured that
maybe somebody would find it or maybe
you would all just lose a nine moves
just like Bill Gates no any ideas that's
okay I'll tell you I'll give it away so
he could have moved his work over she
that work on on right next to the King
on f1 as we call it in chess if it
slides over now the king has an escape
square yeah so Ricky won exactly it
would have been the move so I thought
that was kind of funny that everybody
was making fun of Bill Gates because I
was like well he was winning in this
position so how do chess players think
about when they have more than 30
seconds when you only have 30 seconds
it's more about instincts than thinking
but in the u.s. chess championship
that's going on right now the time
limits are a lot longer does anybody
have a rough guest of how much time each
player has for all their moves on
average more than 30 minutes I'll give
you a hint it's one game a day so if you
only have 30 minutes it would just be an
hour
yeah four hours is pretty close so each
player has about two hours the three
hours so most games last between four
and six hours so chess players they
start by identifying the choices in a
position should I move my King should I
move my knight should I move my rook and
then that's not enough they have to look
at what their opponent might do against
each of these moves and then this is
when your head starts to hurt you have
to see why you're you do against all of
your opponent's different moves and
clock is ticking down all the while even
this type of decision tree we have it in
the very beginning of the game this is
the opening stage of the game so you can
use it while you're playing or while
you're preparing your openings before
the tournament if I play this move in
the opening what might they play I have
to be prepared for that and then it adds
a branches off you can see why chess
players have to study so hard before all
their major competitions and indeed four
to six hours for each game but the
players are spending at least that much
time prior to the game just looking at
all these types of possibilities
especially in the opening in poker
another game that I love you've got a
similar type of decision tree where if
you check or bet you have to decide what
to do against each of your opponent's
actions of course the decision trees are
gonna be a lot shorter but also just you
know this is just one weapon onto one
hand out of many
that's a poker software which just like
in chess poker players and chess players
they use a software programs they kind
of make their study more efficient and
test though not always do you create a
decision tree like this example the
queen is the most powerful piece in
chess I'm really big into getting more
girls and women into tracks as you might
have guessed from the titles of my books
and I think that the first thing up you
should tell a girl who thinks that chess
isn't for them is well the most powerful
piece on the on the board by far is the
Queen and in this position
there's no point of creating a decision
tree for black because if you move
anything but King takes Queen you're
just totally lost right so it would be a
waste of time you just snap the Queen
off the board and on to the next move
sometimes it's also very difficult to
create a decision tree because there's
just way too many options and even if
the game is 4 hours that's still not
enough time to go through every
permutation when you have a tree this
complex the world champion formerly jose
Capablanca from cuba said that in
situations like this he sees one move
ahead but it's the right move which is
really a good technique I recommend that
so why if we don't if we can find the
right if we can play very well even
without using those decision trees this
is one of the reasons that strong chess
players can be playing against multiple
people at once I played up to 40 people
at once in simultaneous exhibition Here
I am giving an simultaneous to an
all-girls class and the thing is I'm not
really thinking I'm just playing on
instincts on each board and then
occasionally the chess champion or a
grandmaster might take time out for one
particularly tough upon it like when
Garry Kasparov played Rex Sinquefield
and be like okay now I'm gonna think and
then at that moment they might actually
construct some kind of rough decision
tree but for the most point it's just
like look at the board and play the
first move you see just like combo
Blanca said the other thing I like about
simultaneous exhibition is the
physicality of it I'm always really
tired after a simultaneous exhibition it
felt like I ran two miles probably
because I did over the course of it and
here is an example of that this is a
piece I did called hula chats with a
dancer friend of mine and the idea was
get a workout in mentally and physically
at the same time because the hula hoops
are really good for your abs
actually I did another kind of physical
chess and workout video
CrossFit chess recently against my
brother can find online so basically the
game is ending a perpetual check those
of you who play chess perpetual check
means that I keep checking you and you
keep moving your King back and forth
neither of us can do better than that if
I don't I'm gonna lose the game if you
don't you're gonna get checkmate in the
thing I like about perpetual check in
terms of Hulett chess is that it's like
an infinite game you agree to a draw but
really there's no ending to the game and
so in that case it would be kind of like
a decision tree long branch and a circle
at the end I also did a hula chess cyma
once nobody got hurt right here that's a
pretty heavy who moves oh it was a
little risky they had to sign waivers
and of course we also do hula chess in
st. Louis the chess capital everything
innovative in chess comes to st. Louis
or starts in st. Louis because this is
really the mecca for four players all
over the world and not just the United
States all over the world
you've got international chess tourists
coming in for events in st. Louis so to
go back to poker for a minute I talked
about how chess grandmasters and
champions give simultaneous exhibitions
well on poker simultaneous exhibitions
aren't just for fun in fact it's a way
that a lot of poker players make their
living the idea is that this is for
instance is a professional poker player
who used to play professional video
games and perhaps he can make only a few
dollars by playing one game at once but
if you play 60 games he makes almost as
many good decisions so maybe his hourly
his a rate per game goes down to two
dollars but now he's making $120 an hour
instead of three dollars so it's about
finding that sweet spot where you're
getting in a lot of volume but you're
also still making good decisions so I
think that's all really interesting and
the the thing about poker and why it's
important for poker and that doesn't
really relate to chess
is by playing so many hands thousands
and thousands of hands he can tell am i
a good player or not right because over
tens of thousands of hands are going to
be able to see am I making good
decisions or bad ones otherwise in a
very small sample size the luck element
is going to prevail and there's probably
some corollaries there with some
investment as well in chess there so
little luck so you can be a
results-oriented you can say well I had
a bad tournament so I probably play
badly I had a good tournament so I
probably played well usually you're
gonna be right in chess and poker it's
not applicable at all but even in oh and
by the way this is a chess and poker
simultaneous that I played once but even
in chess I think that it really helps to
take the long view and my brother and my
father were both chess masters and one
of the things that I think really helped
was that unlike a lot of chess parents
my dad would never be upset or worried
if I had a bad tournament if I tact I
mean he was probably like disappointed
internally but he would never show it
and that's a really smart thing because
ultimately it's the long strategic thing
that's gonna make you a good or a bad
player are you developing good habits
are you improving day by day and poker
we have a expression for this that's
called your poker life is not one game
one day one tournament even one month
but rather it's one long session so
every chess game or every poker hand
that you play is part of the entire
constellation of what you play so you
should kind of build your repertoire and
your habits based on that idea and that
way you don't get hung up on playing too
badly and in one instance in this final
video I want to show you I kind of
demonstrated that theme with a fairy
tale Goldilocks and the thing that
attracted me to the fairytale Goldilocks
is that in the original Goldilocks the
protagonist was actually an old woman so
the story was about an old lady who
ransacked the Bears home and took all
their stuff and then ran away
and as the story age the girl got
younger so some kind of Dorian Gray
thing going on and until this story that
we all know now where it's a it's a
little girl
and so you see her kind of aged through
this and to me it kind of brings up
what's it like to play chess or play
poker your whole life to me it's like so
important to the culture of chess to
have st. Louis as the chess capital
because it's a place where we can really
embrace our test dreams regardless of
how well we're doing in a particular day
or a particular month
so people often ask me if Tess it's a
game or is it an art or is it a science
it's a big question people ask a lot and
to me it's really a lifestyle and a
culture of thinking and learning and
winning and that's why I think it's
really great and we should all be so
happy to call st. Louis the capital of
chess in America